les négociations vont donc reprendre la
sécurité sociale négociations ont
tronqué puisque le principal syndicat de
médecins ne participera pas mais la
caisse d'assurance maladie veut en
quelque sorte tentait le coup de force
pour qu'une convention soit signée avant
la fin du mois bernard chevalier nouvel
épisode dans le conflit entre la caisse
nationale d'assurance maladie et la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français
en effet le président de la caisse a
décidé de poursuivre des négociations
avec la seule fédération des médecins de
france qui est un syndicat minoritaire
la confédération elles resteraient
exclus des rencontres tant qu'elle
maintiendrait sa consigne d'augmentation
unilatérale des tarifs médicaux à ce
sujet caisses d'assurance maladie met au
point un système de surveillance des
honoraires afin de connaître le
pourcentage des praticiens qui
appliquent le nouveau tarif
de son côté la confédération estime
environ 80%
l'effectif des médecins qui ont augmenté
leurs tarifs cette décision de la caisse
traduit le désir de faire aboutir le
projet d'une médecine à double secteur
c'est-à-dire avec des médecins
conventionnés ou à honoraires libres et
d'aligner les dépenses de santé sur les
recettes des caisses le président de la
caisse a également annoncé qu'il allait
demander au gouvernement de retarder
l'application du ticket modérateur
d'ordre public décidée en juillet
dernier et qui doit prendre effet au 1er
mai
de son côté la cgt a condamné la
décision de la caisse maladie de
discuter avec les seules organisations
minoritaires pour éviter la signature je
cite d'une convention au rabais la
centrale syndicale souhaite une
rencontre nationale de toutes les
organisations représentatives des
médecins et assurés sociaux